aujourd'hui j'aimerais paraît un peu
plus de l'ingénierie des vaccins arn car
celle ci est vraiment fabuleuse elle est
en elle même une ode aux avancées
scientifiques spectaculaires des
dernières décennies en génétique et puis
les parallèles frappant entre la science
du vivant et la science du numérique
sont vraiment délicieux mais du coup ça
va faire une vidéo assez technique et
pas très relié aux préoccupations
importantes vis-à-vis des vaccins à arn
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur ce
qu'il ya à savoir au sujet de ces
vaccins je vous renvoie vers la vidéo
précédente de cette série petite
précision avant de commencer notez que
cette vidéo est essentiellement une
mutation de cette ex en articles de père
hubert qui a beaucoup circulé et qui
semble avoir plu à beaucoup d'experts du
domaine
vous le savez sans doute
génétique du vivant est inscrite dans
des structures de données appelée adn
pour acide désoxyribonucléique ou dans
sa version ribonucléique ou quelqu'un on
parle de arn rend gros et je caricature
laden est un disque dur relativement
fiable dont l'information se dégrade peu
alors que la rn est une sorte de mémoire
vive beaucoup plus propice à la lecture
et à la translation en protéines mais
aussi beaucoup moins stable et durable
ces deux longues molécules consiste en
gros en un brin composé de briques
élémentaires appelé base nucléiques dont
l'adn les bases du clip présente son
l'adénine la cytosine la guanine et la
thymine la rn utilisent les mêmes bases
du clic
à l'exception de la thymine qui a
remplacé par de lui rase il en génétique
ses bases nucléiques sont généralement
représentés par la première lettre de
leur nom
ainsi la rn est une sorte de code
constitué uniquement des lettres à ses
gpu
de ce point de vue la rn est alors très
similaire un message qui pourrait
transiter sur internet une lettre
numérique correspond alors un bit
d'information car il a deux états
possibles une lettre génétique
elle comportera deux bits d'information
puisqu'on peut représenter chaque lettre
de l'information génétique avec deux
buts
typiquement remplaçant de lui à part 0 0
le sépare 0 1
le g par 1 0 élu par un an voilà qui
nous permet de mesurer la complexité
algorithmique d'un brin arn l'espace
mémoire d'un tel bruns mesure et en bits
va alors être deux fois le nombre de
lettres du brin d'aillet rennes comme le
vaccin arn de fighter biotech à 4280
quatre lettres on peut dire qu'il a une
taille de 8500 68 kg pitt est comme un
octet est égal à 8 bits d'information
ceci correspond à un poil plus d'un ko
un petit ko seulement à titre de
comparaison un tweet normale correspond
à 280 octets d'information le vaccin à
arn correspond alors à 4,8 seulement et
d'ailleurs le virus sarr skov 2 n'est
pas beaucoup plus compliqué il fait
seulement 7,5 ko l'équivalent de 27 8
seulement vous vous rendez compte
l'humanité tout entière est actuellement
ravagé par l'équivalent de 27 8
qu'en est il de vous autres qui regardez
cette vidéo quelle est selon vous la
complexité de votre adn
d'après vous votre adn
thil plus grand ou plus petit que disons
votre téléphone eh bien j'ai la mauvaise
nouvelle de vous annoncer qu'il est bien
plus petit que votre téléphone
l'adn d'un humain comporte environ 3
milliards de lettres ce qui correspond à
6 milliards de bits et d'information
soit un peu moins d'un gigaoctet et donc
probablement 10 à 100 fois moins que
votre téléphone
ceci dit votre cerveau lui est beaucoup
plus complexe que votre adn et votre
téléphone
il contient pas loin de millions de
milliards de synapses et a donc une
complexité de centaines de téraoctets
pas mal même si bon les centres de
données modernes sont encore plus gros
que ceux là et peuvent parfois dépasser
l'exacte est soit dit mille fois plus
que le cerveau humain
dans les années 70
80 les biologistes ont commencé à
maîtriser de mieux en mieux la rn est
envisagé la possibilité d'injecter des
arn du messager pour donner
l'instruction à nos cellules de produire
certaines protéines soit pour nous
protéger directement contre des
antigènes soit pour être eux mêmes des
antigènes qui entraînerait notre système
immunitaire
vous avez vu la vidéo présente j'espère
que l'effet la connexion deuxième cas
correspond au vaccin
arn mais au début des années 90
l'excitation initial retomba lorsqu'on
se rendit compte que les brins d arn
messagers étrangers éveiller notre
système immunitaire qui cherchait alors
à détruire ces brins d'arn messager
étrangers certains animaux à qui on
avait injecté les rn message est on
arrivé à même à décéder des suites de
cette réaction immunitaire la recherche
sur la thérapie à base d'ail rennes
semblait confronté à un mur la situation
fut particulièrement difficile pour
catta links haricots qui travaillait sur
cette piste en université exigera telle
qu'elle change de domaine de recherche
si elle voulait garder son statut
d'enseignante chercheuse pire encore la
même semaine katalin cas ricco avait été
diagnostiquée d'un cancer et son mari
avaient des preuves de visa qui
l'empêchait de la rejoindre
aux états unis ça devait être une
période décidément très difficile
katalin carrico choisi néo - de
persévérer dans son étude de des
thérapies à arn quitte à être destitué
de son poste prestigieux
les années qui suivirent en collaborant
notamment avec trouve iceman carrico
réussi à identifier la cause de la
réaction immunitaire à savoir la lettre
u u mieux encore en 2005
les deux chercheurs ont découvert une
solution remarquable à ce problème
remplacé lui rase il la lettre lue par
une base nucléiques aux fonctionnalités
semblables mais qui avait l'énorme
avantage de ne pas déclencher une
réaction immunitaire
cette base nucléiques miracle porte le
doux nom de 1 méthyle trois primes
pseudo reid idylle mais bon et
généticiens préfère l'a représenté
uniquement par une lettre notre grecque
qui est la lettre psy enfin avait-on une
solution pour développer des traitements
à arn messager
ceci dit la grande révolution qui
des traitements à arn c'est surtout
l'avancée scientifique et a permis le
développement d'outils pour lire et
écrire
la rn côté lecteurs des systèmes de plus
en plus sophistiquées qui s'appuie
notamment sur des lasers permettent de
lire des suites de lettres de brens
étendue se déplaçant selon une direction
les algorithmes sophistiqués sont alors
utilisés pour deviner quelle mesure les
différents signaux collecter correspond
à la lecture d'un même brun par ailleurs
les brins lui sont généralement des
morceaux de brens beaucoup plus long
d'autres algorithmes sont alors
nécessaires pour déterminer comment les
différentes séquences collectés sont
censés être recollés ensemble de l'autre
côté on dispose désormais d'imprimantes
d'information génétique capable de
coller boutabout toute séquence
prédéterminé de base nucléiques
autrement dit désormais un chercheur
peut envoyer un texte par internet qui
sera reçu par l'imprimante pour ensuite
produire littéralement à la lettre le
brun darren woods adn souhaité le vaccin
à arn sont alors une application
fantastique de toute cette machinerie
fabuleuse très rapidement les chercheurs
ont séquencé le génome de sarov 2 le
virus du coït 19 qui a ensuite été
envoyé par fichier texte à de nombreux
autres chercheurs pour développer un arn
vaccinale adéquat dont on va parler dans
un instant de façon amusante via la
vaccination
toute cette information génétique peut
ensuite voyagé jusque dans nos cellules
qui vont alors exécuter le programme qui
nous permettra de nous protéger contre
locaux vides
19 en ce sens la vaccination est
vraiment une sorte de patch informatique
faut protéger nos organismes contre un
virus informatique photo dans ce cas
virus biologique et d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour vous recommander de mettre
à jour systématiquement vos applications
sur vos ordinateurs et vos téléphones
s'est mise à jour permettra de vacciner
vos programmes contre des vulnérabilités
à des attaques extérieures qui
pourraient prendre le contrôle de vos
machines chiffrés ou détruire vos
données personnelles et publier des
choses sur internet en votre nom
maintenant la vaccination des objets
informatique c'est une question sérieuse
de sécurité notamment pour votre
intégrité mentale
internet tout message sa compagne
systématiquement de toute sorte de méta
données comme le https dans votre garde
adresse le point doc x de votre document
word ou comme l'adresse du destinataire
de vos emails et bien la rn c'est pareil
je pour déterminer comment nos cellules
doivent interpréter un brin d'aillet
rennes se brindas la rn doit être
accompagnée de métadonnées
dans le cas de la rn du vaccin fighter
ces métadonnées sont écrites au début et
à la fin du bras de la rn6 et au milieu
de ce brin d'iron que l'on trouve la
partie qui code pour cette fameuse
protéine spike l'information dans la rn
ouvre avec ce que l'on appelle une
coiffe cinq primes à quoi frontières
deux premières lettres gea qui servent
plusieurs fonctions l'une d'elles est de
dire aux autres composants dans la
cellule je viens du noyau la coiffe est
ensuite accompagné d'un code appelé cinq
prime une théière avec d'autres
métadonnées dans le cas du vaccin
fighter il a été copié collé d'un gène
codant paul de l'alfa globine on a
beaucoup testé précédemment et dont on a
observé les effets bénéfiques sur la
production massive de protéines dans
l'arène
on a ensuite des méta données issues du
virus sarr skov de lui-même appelé
peptides signal qui semble dire où la
protéine doit être transporté après
création puis vient enfin le coeur du
message véhiculé par la rn2 fighter à
savoir l'information à traduire en
protéines spike et sur laquelle on
reviendra un peu plus tard pour finir
avec les métadonnées enfin darren on
trouve trois primes ut air qui lui aussi
a été optimisé pour une production
massive de protéines et enfin on à la
fin de la rn qui s'écrit
[Musique]
parce que 2020 non en fait ceux ci
semblent surtout améliorer les
performances du vaccin
pour nous en maintenant au 3777 lettre
que j'ai sauté qui vont coder des
protéines spike dussart skov de plus
précisément les métadonnées vont faire
qu'un ribosomes va se placer sur la rn
du vaccin fighter le ribosome va alors
lire les lettres trois par trois chaque
trio de lettres est appelé un co dont
chaque colon va être alors traduit en en
acides aminés correspondant à ce colon
au fur et à mesure de la lecture de la
rn par le ribosome une séquence d'acides
aminés va alors être constitué cette
séquence d'acides aminés est la protéine
spike et bien sûr pour produire la même
protéine spike que les protéines spike
dussart skov 2 les chercheurs ont tout
simplement copier coller la rn10 à
roscoff 2 qui code pour ces protéines
spike on peut d'ailleurs le vérifier en
comparant la séquence de la rn dussart
skov 2 à la rn du vaccin fighter et
comme vous le voyez il colle
parfaitement
bon en fait non il ya pas mal de
différences
bon d'un côté il ya eu des substitutions
des u en psy mais même si je remplace
les psys du vaccin fasse heures par des
u ou n'obtient alors des séquences de
base une clique différentes
que se passe-t-il si vous avez une idée
vient de se trouve qu'il ya 20 acides
aminés pour 4 x 4 x 4 est égal à 64 go
dont possible
clairement il ne peut pas y avoir une
traduction 1 à 1 entre colon et acides
aminés et bien comme on le voit dans ce
tableau il se trouve que la plupart des
acides aminés sont codées par des colons
différents ainsi eu du produit de la
phénylalanine méhul c'est aussi du coup
en remplaçant le uae dussart skov 2 par
un humus et dans le vaccin fasse heures
plus tôt même par un pipe 6 et où ne
change on en fait pas à la séquence
d'acides aminés et donc la protéine
qu'on fabrique ainsi deux encore les
biologistes ont compris que certains
qu'oddo était plus efficace pour la
production de protéines que d'autres
c'est ainsi que plusieurs lettres ont
été modifiés pour produire la même
protéine mais avec une meilleure
efficacité
autres différences mineures la
programmation de la protéine spike se
termine par des colons qui signale cette
fin il semble que pour le vaccin fighter
biotech
ce signal de fin a été répétée en double
sans doute par mesure de sécurité
et donc si on se con
uniquement ces opérations d'optimisation
de production de la protéine on se
retrouve avec la même protéine spike que
la protéine spike du cers co2 oui mais
en pratique il ne suffit pas d'avoir la
même suite das examiné pour que les deux
protéines se comporte de la même manière
en effet comme l'expliquent notamment
science étonnante et patience dans ces
superbes vidéos
d'un point de vue fonctionnel ce qui
emporte ce ne sont pas les séquences
d'acides aminés des protéines
ce qui importe ce sont les
configurations spatiales que ces
protéines prennent dans leur
environnement
or sur le cers cov 2 la configuration
spatiale de la protéine ce pack vient du
fait que cette protéine est collé à la
membrane du virus
sans cette membrane la protéine spike
seul ne se remplira pas de la même
manière
et ça ça veut dire en particulier qui
n'active ra pas la bonne réponse
immunitaire
c'est là que vient une astuce de génie
cette asus de génie inspiré des études
sur les virus sarce cauvin et sur le
meurtre c'est de modifier légèrement la
séquence d'acides aminés de la protéine
spike via une substitution par une
double proline pour que la protéine
spahic modifier ce repli comme la
protéine spike monté sur la membrane du
virus
incroyable avec cette astuce les pseudos
protéines spike produite dans nos
cellules
grâce à la rn et des vaccins fighter
vont quasiment activer le système
immunitaire de la même manière que le
sascoc 2h15 à ce sujet je me permet de
lire cette citation tirée de l'article
qui a inspiré cette vidéo dans parce que
je trouve cette citation très drôle
je cite les gens qui ont découvert cela
devrait se balader en s'auto
applaudissant sans fin une impression
insupportable de suffisance devrait
émaner 2 et ce serait tout à fait
méritée et bien en fait non les auteurs
de cette découverte ou répondu avec
énormément de modération et d'humilité
et finalement ça s'est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus classe encore
nous vivons dans un monde complexe avec
des défis monumentaux dont les
résolutions nécessite la combinaison
d'un très grand nombre de coups de génie
mais aussi le d'exploration de piste qui
ne mèneront à rien parfois pendant des
mois des années des décennies voire qui
ne mèneront peut-être jamais à rien mais
si on n'avait pas investi dans ces
pistes inexplorées
si on n'avait pas pris le temps
d'encourager la recherche fondamentale
et si on ne valorise et pas l'expertisé
l'humilité vis-à-vis de l'expertisé des
autres
alors on n'aurait eu aucune chance de
découvrir la structure de l'information
génétique des arn de découvrir les
propriétés salvatrice du 1 mai t-il
trois primes pseudo reid idylle ou de
découvrir l'astuce de la substitution
par la double proline et si on
n'encourage pas davantage toutes ces
recherches de longue haleine on aura
peut-être aucune chance de résoudre les
nombreux autres grands défis de
l'humanité qui se poseront au 21e siècle
qu'il s'agisse de combattre le
changement climatique de réduire les
inégalités sociales ou de rendre les
algorithmes robustement bénéfique